what a wonderful day for some kayaking
out on the open sea
wait a second
why is the water spiraling
is this a whirlpool
how could you end up getting sucked in
what would spinning down that drain feel
like
[Music]
and what would happen if you had a
bigger boat
this is what if and here's what would
happen if you were sucked into a
whirlpool
maybe you've seen it in the movies a
powerful spiral of water
boats helplessly spin toward the ocean
floor with barely any odds of survival
there are lots of mythical stories about
the dangers of whirlpools yet they do
pop up frequently around the world
whirlpools form when two opposing
currents meet
if they're strong enough these rotating
currents start to wrap around each other
creating a spiral of fast-moving water
as the spiral intensifies a cavity opens
at the center
the vortex or vacuum effect could be
powerful enough to pull objects down to
the sea floor
but not only objects get caught in these
maelstroms
people do too
people
like you
paddling your kayak off the coast of
norway's lofoten islands
you'd find yourself in some very rough
waters
that's because you'd stumble across or
rather into the muskstroman maelstrom
say that five times fast
this is one of the most famous
whirlpools in the world
it was a source of inspiration for
authors like edgar allan poe and jules
verne
but there wouldn't be just
one whirlpool to worry about
there would be several and you'd find
yourself approaching the biggest one of
all
with a diameter of 40 to 50 meters this
maelstrom has a length of four school
buses
and its currents move at a powerful
speed of 32 kilometers per hour
big ripples and strong waves would
threaten to knock you out of your kayak
and eventually they'd succeed
now you'd be in trouble
you'd try to swim away from the current
but it would be too strong
all this turbulence and spinning would
make you dizzy and disoriented you'd be
pushed underwater for a moment and then
thrust back up gasping for air
the whirlpool would pull you closer and
closer to the center of the vortex
you'd see the water forming in the shape
of an inverted bell
narrowing to a point somewhere deep in
the ocean
you'd make one last attempt to swim to
safety but you'd be exhausted and out of
luck
the water would take total control
you'd get dragged down under the surface
of the water and you'd better be able to
hold your breath you'd start to think
you're a goner and that you'll keep
going deeper in a never-ending spiral
but eventually you hit the bottom of the
ocean floor
you wouldn't have a moment to catch your
thoughts
you'd need air
but now you'd be swept up fast in a
deeper ocean current
the whirlpool above would start to fade
into the distance
finally out of its grip you'd muster all
your strength and swim to the surface
you could be very deep underwater so
you'd struggle and struggle
you'd feel your lungs about to burst and
just when you think you're not going to
make it you'd break the surface
it gasped for air
the rough ocean water still raging
around you
but your life would still be in danger
the ocean waters in these parts would be
frigid and like over half of the people
who die in cold water
you'd start to suffer from cold
incapacitation
you'd lose control of your arms and legs
keeping your head above the surface
would be almost impossible
you'd feel like you couldn't hold on any
longer but then a life buoy is tossed in
your direction
you'd look up and see a big fishing boat
rescue
once safe and shivering on the boat
you'd wrap yourself in dry blankets to
avoid hypothermia
you'd try to thank the fishermen but
you'd be in shock from your near-death
experience
and you wouldn't be completely safe yet
shouts would echo through the ship the
big boat is now caught in the same
whirlpool you just escaped
the boat would struggle against the
water with the motor sputtering and
propellers lifting out of the water
with no traction you'd think you were
doomed
but just then the propeller would catch
the water again and with one big surge
the boat would escape the pull of the
vortex into calmer waters
you and the fishermen would finally take
a deep breath of cold sea air
and you'd thank your lucky stars that it
wasn't a giant sea monster like the
kraken trying to pull you under
because that sounds like a story
for another
what if